l'image est choquant
elle montre la mort en direct de john
floyd le coup coincé sous le genou d'un
policier
il se plaint de ne pas pouvoir respirer
les passants implore le policier de
lever le genou mais il reste impassible
les mains dans les poches
georges floyd saigne du nez perd
connaissance avant d'être emmené et
conscience une civière
il est déclaré mort à son arrivée à
l'hôpital dans un premier temps la
police affirme qu'il a résisté à son
arrestation
ces images prouvent le contraire dans la
communauté noire de minneapolis la
colère gronde
difficile de ne pas y voir encore le
comportement raciste d'un policier blanc
contre un homme noir pour cette
manifestante
c'est un message dur est simple ni les
autorités de la ville réagissent
rapidement les quatre policiers
impliqués dans l'arrestation sont
licenciés oui sort whiterock le maire
visiblement ébranlé par ce qu'il a vu
ce policier blanc a mis son genou sont
tus d'un homme noir pendant cinq minutes
dit il cet officier a failli à son
devoir le plus basique son devoir
d'homme snec aubrac même être noirs en
amérique ajoute il ne devrait pas être
une sentence de mort ping doit à cannes
merkel n'a pas été atteint l'enquêté a
été confiée au fbi a permis à la famille
de la victime demande justice ils
doivent être condamnés pour meurtre dit
le frère de john floyd
chaque jour depuis le drame les
habitants de minneapolis manifestent
leur rage dans la rue le lien de
confiance avec la police déjà fragile
est rompu il faut dire que l'agent derek
chauvin a déjà fait l'objet de plusieurs
plaintes pour violence dans le passé
tout classer sans suite
un drame qui n'est pas sans rappeler la
mort en géorgie dawod arbres y un
joggeur poursuivi est tué à coup de
fusil par un ancien policier et son fils
en février dernier il aura fallu la
publication d'une vidéo du meurtre pour
que les auteurs présumés soient arrêtés
la sphère de minneapolis en tout cas est
en train de prendre une ampleur
nationale
beaucoup de vedettes comme le basketteur
professionnel lebron james
s'exprimant publiquement sur le drame
comme beaucoup d'autres avant lui
djordje floyd est en train de devenir un
symbole des violences policières contre
les noirs ce qui attriste son ancien
employeur et amis fleuve n'est pas
seulement un homme noir tué par un
policier blanc dit il il était surtout
quelqu'un de bien
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
washington